salut à tous bienvenue sur envergure
épisode spécial jeune talent féminin
français aujourd'hui les joueuses les
plus prometteuses des générations
2005-2006 2007 en état
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et oui car nous avons malgré tous nos
échecs face à l'Espagne ramenés un titre
amphiba jeune cet été les U16 filles la
médaille d'or pour elle on va présenter
cette génération on va parler également
de l'équipe
U17 bronzé mais au championnat du monde
mais U16 c'était au championnat d'Europe
pour en parler nous avons seniors Steve
bonjour salut
[Musique]
extraordinaire donc romain notre
deuxième membre envergure pour parler
des filles évidemment puisque la
médaille de bronze des U17 toi tu l'as
aussi tu lâches
avec la médaille alors cette fois-ci la
FIBA monde a une délicatesse des boîtes
pour mettre les médailles puisque la
mienne est en espèce de porcelaine par
la petite histoire elle est actuellement
dans une boîte accompagnée de la
médaille que j'ai ramené du championnat
d'Europe U18 il y a quelques années
également en grec bon
endroit ouais c'est vrai la Hongrie
comme quoi c'est pas que pas que du
malheur et de l'autre
donc notre premier je veux dire le
premier thème la première la première
joueuse dont on va parler
dans ce podcast puisqu'on va on a essayé
de faire des groupes alors évidemment
c'est c'est difficile à cet âge là c'est
niveau de compétition qui sont un peu
variables mais il y a quand même une
joueuse parmi toutes ces générations qui
sort du lot c'est Dominique Malonga
qui jouait donc en U17 qui a fait un
énorme tournoi romain est-ce que tu peux
nous présenter le profil de cette
joueuse qui vraiment un fort potentiel
alors Dominique je suis allé juste
vérifier la taille pour ne pas dire de
bêtises parce que j'ai un 98 non on doit
être Dominique c'est
[Musique]
une joueuse qui est actuellement las
veulent qui a fait un passage par le
Centre fédéral et qui a rejoint de la
semaine l'an dernier que les petits
pépins physiques c'est ces dernières
saisons mais bon c'est c'est globalement
inhérent à la croissance sur le
développement en grande partie en tout
cas j'espère
elle a pour moi les qualités d'une
joueuse qui peut devenir une joueuse
générationnelle dans le sens où
vrai et puis basket
capacité à se mettre au travail
la quantité d'ego et de personnalité
qu'il faut pour pouvoir jouer un niveau
détermination qui est quand même très
intéressant une fille qui a éduquée moi
que j'aime beaucoup à titre perso sur le
plan humain parce que c'est quelqu'un
avec qui on peut parler échanger et
c'est quelqu'un qui malheureait son
jeune âge est déjà dans un
dans des process de routine de prise en
charge perso qui qui facilitent tout et
bon nous arjons en cours de prépa parce
que c'est un petit peu le petit peu un
petit peu le deal aussi sur sur son
carré et vraiment et parce qu'on a
participé je crois au dû faire le
basketball aux autres borders cet été me
semble-t-il avant de nous rejoindre
aussi donc ça ça vérifié j'en suis plus
je me souviens plus du du cas précédent
mais en tout cas quoi qu'il arrive une
joueuse sur un profil pas vraiment
quatre apparemment 5 mais avec des
qualités des qualités qui permettent de
d'être un petit peu entre les deux
postes une vraie mobilité des mains
tu m'as le droit tu as développé mais
des choses qui me laissent
envisager un futur serein en sachant
qu'il y a la verticalité il y a la
longueur c'est bon une belle chose elle
est en 1810 sur la compétition en
moyenne 18 points dit rebonds donc un
double double sur une compétition FIBA
c'est pas si courant
et et alors on parle de ses mains moi ce
qui m'a ce qui m'a beaucoup plu en
termes de chiffres évidemment j'ai
regardé match qui m'a beaucoup plu c'est
l'adresse au lancer franc dans les
matchs importants on va dire avec un 11
sur 15 matchs
la difficulté en fait sur sa mise en
route c'est qu'elle a pas énormément
joué cette année
donc il a fallu en fait elle a pas
énormément joué elle a fait 400 tours de
préparation avec nous donc il a fallu
qu'elle monte un régime alors on ira
tout à l'heure mais les compètes de cet
été sont les rendements statistiques de
certaines joueuses sont un peu biaisés
parce que globalement que ce soit en U16
ont eu 17 sorties du top 4 top 5 des
équipes genre mon niveau très très
aléatoire on a joué on a joué
l'Argentine ampoule qui était quand même
une bonne division en dessous et c'est
comme ça que des joueuses des joueuses
d'autres nations sans trouver à
surperformer statistique
notamment le cas d'une chose allemande
qui était qui était sur un match à 30
avant de jouer contre nous et
un petit peu pris le mur elle s'est
faite concassée donc dans le cadre
d'hommes en fait ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'elle a elle a super formé face
à des équipes
qui avaient des clients en face et où
physiquement elle s'est un petit peu
parce que aussi notamment bah l'Espagne
Canada où il y avait il y avait très
belle joueuse face à elle et moi c'est
ce qui fait dans cette variable c'était
qu'elle a eu à se transposer sur ces
rencontres là et impacter ses rencontres
là c'est ces choses là qui me laissent
penser que l'avenir peut être assez beau
si au niveau santé elle trouve elle
trouve quelque chose un terrain
intéressant
Steve est-ce que au-delà de ce qu'a déjà
dit romain tu as d'autres choses à noter
qui t'ont plu dans le dans le jeu de ma
longueur
oui il y a déjà bon au niveau des stats
c'est la meilleure evolte du tournoi
c'est largement il a vraiment été
dominante sur tous les matchs à la
portée c'était vraiment la chose la plus
importante de l'équipe après sur les
aspects un peu plus un peu plus basket
il y a eu des il y a eu des flashs comme
ça sur le sur le tir qui m'ont beaucoup
plus sur le tir mi distance sur le sur
les longs deux et sur les drive
c'est-à-dire que on l'a vu dans
certaines situations ce qui a été
utilisé par exemple peut-être de
raquettes pour jouer sur du main à main
on l'a vu sur certaines situations
prendre des tirs pas hésiter
on l'a vu aussi parfois à les poser un
dribble voire deux dribbles en ligne
droite pour l'instant elle est capable
de poser la balle au sol
les équipes qui nous ont joué aurait dû
regarder jouer un peu la SIG ces
dernières années
quelques petites choses du PlayBook pour
et pour comment dire pour Marine durcius
d'abord une situation qu'on utilisait
beaucoup et que j'ai transposé ensuite
parce que donne naturellement est
capable d'attaquer comme on dit en
anglais
c'est à dire qu'elle est vraiment
capable de partir en ligne droite sur sa
main quand c'est ouvert et on a fait en
sorte de l'isoler justement sur des sur
un écran un petit peu Ghost et qu'elle
enchaîner directement sur réception
attrapé jouer et c'est un petit peu
médical en difficulté là-dessus
effectivement
vas-y Steve on l'a gardé on avait gardé
son magasin le plus longtemps possible
et on a on a sorti du carton quand il a
fallu pardon Je te laisse
et le fait est qu'en plus elle s'est
très bien adaptée à ce nouveau rôle
entre guillemets pas ce nouveau rôle
mais à avoir ce laba le ballon dans
cette zone alors qu'elle l'avait pas
forcément eu dans les autres matchs donc
c'est intéressant
Steve est-ce qu'il y a d'autres choses
drive voilà poser la balle au sol c'est
vraiment cette taille là c'est ça c'est
un mètre 98 c'est pas beaucoup de filles
même au niveau professionnel même au
niveau qui qui sont capables de draguer
voilà de poser un de dribbles comme ça
et d'être efficace dans ces situations
là donc ça c'est hyper impressionnant
j'avais noté aussi
6 fautes seulement sur la compétition
alors qu'elle est sollicitée évidemment
elle est protectrice de cercle alors
c'était pas la seule de l'équipe mais 9
contre très interception seulement si
faute c'est excellent sont des chiffres
vraiment excellents et alors tu disais
romain évidemment ça relativisait avec
des matchs face à des nations un peu un
peu moins fortes d'ailleurs elle pose
trois interceptions contre
l'Argentine voilà qui est pas qui est
pas forcément une grosse nation mais
mais il y a deux contre ce compte
espagnol de mi de contre le Canada en
finale à chaque fois elle fait elle
prend que deux fautes c'est c'est pas
c'est ça ça prend enfin ça s'apprend
mais je veux dire c'est c'est presque
inné la discipline qu'elle a
défensivement romain ouais c'est c'est
quelqu'un de très disciplié très
scolaire mais encore une fois c'est
quelqu'un qui qui
dans sa façon d'être quelqu'un de très
intelligent et de très à l'écoute et
très alerte donc quand on a des gens
comme ça c'est quand même beaucoup plus
facile de les driver après après je
dirais malgré tout que
il y a comme une
capacité à
comment dire elle a encore de la marge
dans le fait de pouvoir chercher à
impacter les gens physiquement je pense
que c'est un petit quelque chose qu'elle
peut avoir en plus mais effectivement
mis à part de mémoire contre le Canada a
repris défensif qu'elle fait ou sur le
banc
[Musique]
on a eu on a tous retenus notre
respiration parce que si la contact est
que l'arbitre prend ça peut être anti
sportif parce qu'elle est derrière
dernier défenseur et compagnie
petite histoire ça sera plus nous coûter
nous coûter un petit peu cher mais
malgré tout la sureste sous contrôle et
c'est quelqu'un qui justement c'est le
terme dans ce qu'elle fait en
attaquement c'est sous contrôle il y a
du contrôle ça manque encore un petit
peu parfois de dureté en attaquant mais
il y a du contrôle il maîtrise de ce
qu'elle fait au niveau physique ce qui
est assez ce qui est assez énorme
quel Steve qu'elle pisse de
quelle partie du jeu tu la verrais
développé en priorité voilà pour pour
continuer son développement vers parce
qu'on imagine ce qu'on espère être une
belle carrière au niveau de la dureté je
suis assez d'accord aussi parce que même
si elle a pris énormément de rebonds sur
la compétition parfois elle fait se fait
un peu bouger sur les impacts sur les
écrans retard et pour être encore plus
dominante avec sa taille sur cet aspect
là
et sur le bah moi le tir je pense que si
elle est capable de s'écarter de manière
efficace ça va être juste être un
jouable en fait ça va être vraiment très
compliqué de défendre sur elle parce
qu'elle pourra rouler parce qu'elle
pourra pourra flairer elle pourra elle
pourra driver en attaque ça va juste
devenir tenir vraiment à quelqu'un de
très très performant donc le la dureté
et puis le théâtre qui a capable de
s'écarter un peu moi c'est trop perso
enfin ces modèles justement c'était
management campagne
international 8 chez les filles
mis à part et je ne vais surtout pas
comparer les joueuses et c'est pas le
propos mais mise à part ils donnent
Huppert que j'ai eu en
U15 je n'ai pas vu de joueuses récemment
à avoir ce rapport
détermination écoute qualité de travail
et potentialité
[Musique]
à l'entraînement c'est vraiment vraiment
quelqu'un de de très intéressant sous
énormément d'aspects
à quel niveau est-ce que tu sais à quel
niveau elle va jouer
moi dans ces pistes de développement
j'avais noté en magasiné de la culture
de jeu parce que comme tu dis elle est
scolaires et elle a ses moves elle sait
qu'elle sait les faire elle a un drive
direct au panier là un spin-move qu'elle
maîtrise assez bien maintenant en
magasiner de la culture de jeu ça veut
dire pouvoir peut-être faire la passe un
petit peu plus tôt quand il y a besoin
de faire la passe et qu'elle a créé le
décalage ça veut dire avoir des
contre-moves quand la défense va
anticiper ses mouvements à quel niveau
elle va jouer pour emmagasiner cette
culture de jeu là déjà c'est quelqu'un
qui s'intéresse à ce qu'elle fait j'ai
parfois eu des joueuse dans l'équipe de
France de très bon niveau certaines sont
arrivés en Ligue féminine par plus mais
qui avait pas forcément de démarches de
vouloir plus d'infos elle donne
systématiquement quand on joue elle veut
les matchs quand elle est arrivée avec
nous elle a demandé des matchs qu'on
avait déjà joué en préparation avant
donc il y a il y a encore il y a dans sa
démarche personnelle
l'envie d'avancer après là aujourd'hui
elle va être elle va être à l'as bien
alors il y a un changement de un
changement de coach un changement de
staff au niveau du club au niveau de
l'équipe pro c'est David Gauthier là qui
était donc à Angers qui est également
assistant d'équipe de France a qui
récupère la boutique et qui je pense et
quelqu'un qui est tout à fait à même
d'accompagne une joie dans son
développement parce que lui déjà une
belle carrière de joueurs
stopper un petit peu tôt pour des
raisons liées au à des pépins physiques
malgré tout une belle carrière de
joueurs et dans l'accompagnement il a
fait du très bon boulot à Angers parfois
avec des bouts de ficelle ou parfois
avec des rosters plus limités que
d'autres pouvaient avoir même si en
Ligue 2 il avait il avait des moyens
importants pour la division donc c'est
pour moi quelqu'un qui peut tout à fait
l'amener à l'amener à passer un cap pour
ne pas dire pour ne pas dire puis Center
de maturité mais ça reste une chose
intérieure joueuse de grande taille avec
cette petite prédisposition aux blessure
et ça prendra iné un petit peu plus de
temps pour une joueuse de profil un peu
plus un peu plus classique bien
évidemment
est-ce que l'un ou l'autre avait des
choses à ajouter
ah non j'avais une dernière question
pour toi romain évidemment moi j'ai
regardé j'étais pas Hongrie donc je
regardais mes matchs sur Youtube
d'ailleurs ils sont accès libre si vous
voulez voir jouer Dominique Malonga
c'est c'est gratuit
comment elle communique défensivement
parce qu'on attend d'une joueuse
intérieure souvent qu'elle qu'elle soit
un peu la chef de la défense qu'elle
encore encore vous-même comme disent
elle a elle a un leadership naturel
par sa présence sur l'Oracle sur son
groupe parce que c'est ça reste à jouer
de référence de de un petit peu de de la
génération elle forme avec adjacan un
duo un duo sur et en dehors du terrain
qui qui est intéressant
parce que ça donne un petit peu de vie
dans tout ça
c'est quelqu'un qui est capable de
parler qui est capable de communiquer
qui est
qui a une présence vraiment rassurante
même pour les autres parce que comme si
un leader technique et ça c'est un
leader de génération inévitablement
quand la meilleure joueuse d'une
génération est présente les autres par
effet le groupe sont tout de suite plus
plus alerte et impactés c'est elle elle
amène ça directement après dans l'aspect
technique en défense j'ai envie de dire
que nous dans le dans l'organisation que
que Vincent bourdon le coach avait mis
en place on avait un petit peu calé les
choses par rapport à elle et par rapport
au profit qu'on avait parce qu'on avait
on avait une équipe avec quand même pas
mal de taille finalement et de jouer sur
des profils physiques tout un peu
différents mais avec de la taille elle a
su si elle a su s'y adapter et il
trouvait sa place
même si on a du Massier quelques petits
trucs également après c'est toujours
pareil ça reste une complète du 17 face
à des joueuses qui pour pour l'essentiel
n'était pas de son
son impact ou son son efficacité
actuelle la transposition en seniors je
pense qu'il va falloir gagner généralité
un petit peu et en explosivité mais ça
c'est pour tout le monde donc pour
toutes les choses intérieures donc moi
j'ai pas j'ai pas de Red Flag en tout
cas ni d'inquiétude sur la capacité qu'à
l'aurait à
comment dire à être efficace dans les
aspects défensifs à haut niveau ok très
bien Steve as-tu des choses à ajouter à
propos de Dominique Malonga joueuse de
l'ASVEL non rien de particulier déjà 8
apparitions pro on peut le dire quand
même déjà du 8 matchs de LFB voilà donc
peut-être que ça va augmenter la saison
prochaine bien sûr ouais à suivre donc
un talent assez rare du côté de de
l'équipe de France U17 cet été on espère
évidemment que son corps la laissera
tranquille c'est tu sais jamais donner
évidemment pour pour les joueuses de
cette taille on va enchaîner avec des
joueuses qu'on parle potentiel de de
Dominique Malonga sur le papier mais qui
ont fait bonne impression cet été qui
pourrait pourquoi pas avoir un avenir en
pro
Steve je te laisse commencer que ce soit
U16 ou
U17 que tu veux commencer par qui on va
commencer par la plus jeune
à Inoa je sais pas si ça se dit comme ça
à Inoa riz haché alors il y avait quand
même deux hein dans cette équipe U16 qui
est très
comment dire particulier puisque c'est
pas un prénom très très courant
c'est ça donc fille de Stéphane rizacher
sœur de Zacharie ils achètent donc c'est
une joueuse alors surclassée sur la
campagne donc c'est une 2007 qui jouait
était 2006 sera sur le roux 16
aviez voulu à l'ASVEL et si une joueuse
extérieure on va dire de
1m85
donc c'est une de ces premières qualités
c'est qu'elle est très très grande pour
sa mobilité qu'elle a des bras une
envergure donc j'ai pas les j'ai pas les
mesures mais qui est visuellement c'est
impressionnante
à la capacité de faire beaucoup de
choses sur un terrain elle arrive à
driver elle a posé des écrans elle était
utilisé plutôt sur post 4 donc c'est
elle qui pose les écrans par exemple sur
des doubles écran elle peut défendre
plusieurs positions de trois quatre donc
elle est hyper intéressante hyper
polyvalente et elle a un jeu sans ballon
qui est intéressant et c'est plutôt une
bonne passeuse pour l'anecdote j'ai
il y a Arnaud du pilote donc son
sélectionneur sur la campagne qui est
venu faire un clinique pour le comité
parisien du basketball il y a quoi deux
trois semaines et il nous expliquait que
quand il voulait sauter une une somme
presse c'est elle qui mettait au milieu
l'immédiane parce que c'était la
meilleure passeuse de l'équipe et la
meilleure joueuse sans ballon et on l'a
vu aussi en finale contre l'Espagne
c'est elle qui a qui jouait sur le poste
haut lors de la défense de zone
espagnole sur la 2 3 donc comme entre
guillemets deuxième menace de jeu voilà
la finale gagnée face à face à l'Espagne
effectivement alors
moi j'ai peut-être un bémol sur la
mobilité
utiliser notamment défensivement j'ai vu
des pas sûr qu'elle pourra défendre des
deux à terme romain je sais pas à quel
point tu as vu c'est dur aussi
je l'ai survolé parce que ça correspondu
à au moment où
on est en pleine reprise donc ça a pas
été forcément très simple de suivre donc
j'ai pas j'ai pas d'avis arrêté sur je
suis sur la plupart des choses mon
système mes deux administrés que j'ai eu
cette condoublait
même à ma question du coup ça serait à
quel point une joueuse de stage là donc
toute jeune à 15 ans
à quel point elle peut elle va améliorer
sa mobilité latérale notamment parce que
c'est ça qui me qui me chiffonne le plus
avec elle on va dire c'est
c'est très difficile à évaluer avec
précision parce que on se rend compte
que même sur des sur des joueurs plus
âgés ou plus mature qu'on peut vous
trouver au niveau universitaire parfois
on se gaufre on se disant que ça avance
en fait non ou l'inverse donc c'est
quand même pas quelque chose de très
simple donc il y a toujours il y a
toujours un potentiel un potentiel inné
qui qui sera ou facteur améliorant ou
facteurs limitant du développement de la
joueuse et après il y a l'espèce de de
petite partie qu'on peut qu'on peut
optimiser par un travail spécifique
je pense malgré tout que bon un mètre 85
à son âge
elle peut peut-être encore pousser un
petit peu est-ce que cela nous
extérieurs tout le long je ne sais pas
et après dans quel cas est-ce que dans
quel cadre veut dire est-ce que va
pouvoir vraiment être capable de
défendre ou pas je veux dire aujourd'hui
être au niveau on se rend compte public
comme avec sa chartereau qui a la
spécialité sur le tir sur son poste qui
est une 4 avec ça c'est pas le défenseur
de l'année par contre elle sait très
bien faire ses fautes et Alexia malgré
tout c'est quelqu'un que son équipe
nationale ou en club on arrive à cacher
un petit peu et on accepte sur ces
profils un petit peu spécifiques de
d'avoir peut-être un peu de un peu de
jeu en défense quand je dis un peu de
jeu c'est un peu de un peu de comment
dire de
un peu de moins bien défensif parce que
l'impact se fera ailleurs
je j'aimerais avoir le package c'est
toujours pareil les filles en U16
elles ont joué deux matchs en fait oui
parce que parce qu'elles se sont rendus
parcours facile d'une part et d'autre
part mis à part l'Espagne où elles ont
joué un petit peu plus elles ont joué 45
minutes 40 globalement globalement elles
ont pas rencontré l'adversaire trop
compliqué avant avant l'emballage final
donc
ça me paraît complexe à complexe à
vraiment évaluer y compris sur les
aspects physiques face à des jouets ce
qui
la plupart des pays je pense sont en
plein en plein retour de bâton de
l'effet quavide aussi et
c'était peut-être pas
moi je perplexe sur l'évaluation brute
sur des matchs autre que autre que je
suis de la de la croisière de la finale
de toute façon j'ai effectivement gardé
demi-finale finale j'avoue
la finale je me suis contenté des stats
pour le reste Steve juste un mot sur son
tir ce qu'elle peut est-ce qu'elle peut
shooter ce qui est une gestuelle qui est
correcte
j'ai pas vraiment vu son tir ouais moi
non plus
je la voyais pas dans ce registre là
j'ai pas vu beaucoup de tiré donc mais
en tout cas
deux styles de moyenne sur la compète la
volé beaucoup de ballons elle est longue
et vraiment en fait je trouve qu'elle a
un peu les mêmes qualités que son frère
dont on a déjà parlé dans le podcast
elle a elle a une rapidité de de penser
le jeu que ce soit offensivement
défensivement qui est supérieur à la
moyenne surtout par rapport à son âge et
ça lui permet d'être hyper en avance sur
les aides enfin ça lui permet de
compenser en fait ce petit manque de
latéralité que je trouve et
peut-être elle a un petit peu les mêmes
défauts aussi je dirais que que Zacharie
qui pour le moment mais c'est des choses
qui peuvent changer mais pas et pas
encore prêt dans l'appréhension du
contact
en tout cas c'était son défaut majeur
sur les derniers matchs que j'avais
donc voilà ce que ce que j'avais à dire
sur
je vais continuer avec pour ma part une
joueuse qui est évoluait à l'intérieur
dans l'équipe U17 donc que Romain
coacher
j'ai plutôt plutôt que adjacan donc tu
as parlé romain et qui je trouve à des
très bons fondamentaux pour son rôle etc
mais qui manque peut-être de main j'ai
préféré moi le potentiel de Ramona Vita
qui joue à la svelle qui est une 2005
débute c'est une des plus vieilles
joueuses de la compétition c'est du
début janvier 2005 un mètre 90 et en
fait grande avec un vrai tir un vrai
QI j'ai trouvé donc des bonnes mains
mobilité etc alors évidemment elle est
très fine elle est subissait parfois le
contact elle pas forcément l'impact
qu'on attend d'une chose intérieure mais
en revanche c'est assez rare de voir
des mains comme ça sur une joueuse de
cette taille romain qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce que tu as à
dire sur ramonavita alors Ramona
toute black possible avec Diane etc etc
par rapport au nom bien sûr j'ai vécu
l'entrée avant de les faire
ramonage je l'ai croisé à deux tourments
différents je l'ai eu en U15 ce que
j'étais avec la base de cette génération
à U15 notamment Ramona jackan par
exemple c'est des filles que j'ai eu
avec lui il y a 3 ans
pensionnaire de l'ASVEL également
on s'est posé pas mal de questions sur
l'utilisation et sur sur le fait de
l'avoir à la fin à l'arrivée dans les 12
et elle a gagné sa place petit à petit
nous a vraiment rassuré sur sur la
dernière partie de la préparation et
puis de fil en aiguille elle a gagné
elle a gagné sa place avec des minutes
et on lui a trouvé même je dirais une
une polyvalence défensive parfois qu'on
imaginait pas parce qu'elle était
capable même sans être trop vocale
d'aller vraiment au mastic et sur les
switch on a peu été embêté avec elle
elle a fait des choses très
intéressantes que ce soit contre
Allemagne Espagne et même Canada
les cercles 3 matchs qui ont vraiment
compté un quart de mie et match pour le
bronze avec un abattage au rebond
notamment rebondois parce que comme
chercher quatre bons contre les
Espagnols
dans un dans un match qui était qui
était plus que plus que tendu c'est
d'ailleurs je crois que son meilleur
match de la compétition de mémoire je
sais pas si c'est pas ce match connaît
plus de tir à 2 m 2/3 à 3 points contre
l'ESP dans un dans l'attraper tirer elle
a eu plusieurs fois
on va dire des longs deux puisque les
trois parce que pied sur la ligne parce
que vraiment juste dans le dans le long
périmètre mais c'est quelqu'un qui
a encore de la marge je pense parce
qu'il est c'est encore très long j'ai
lignes
qui doit gagner un petit peu en dureté
malgré tout parce que c'est encore un
petit peu un petit peu gentil et un
petit peu un petit peu calme par contre
quand ça quand ça brasse un petit peu
elle a pas peur de de vraiment y aller
et
je trouve que pour la projection à haut
niveau sur sur une joueuse de rôle sur
une 4 sur une carte comme ça ça peut
être quelque chose de quelque chose de
d'intéressant je suis rassuré c'est
exactement je lis mes notes qui datent
de l'époque j'ai pas revu de match j'ai
marqué avec en gagnant de la force pour
être devenir une arme en switch
elle pourrait se tailler un rôle de
stretch free Andy en 4 qui est plutôt en
tout cas qu'on voit pas forcément
et qui est utile aussi toujours utile
d'avoir un rôle quand on veut se tailler
une bout de carrière pro depuis pareil
c'est une jeune joueuse avec une entrée
d'habilité intéressante et
dans la génération qu'on avait qui est
pareil qui est très complémentaire des
autres donc c'est aussi pour ça que le
le quatuor à l'intérieur qu'elle
composait avec avec Cannes Malonga et
Djoko était quand même plutôt plutôt
intéressant parce que c'était que des
joueuses sur des profits différents
Steve je sais pas si tu as quelque chose
à dire sur ramonavita non parce que
j'aime bien le tir aussi mais
[Musique]
elle elle fait trois sur 8 à 3 points
sur la compète donc ça paraît pas
beaucoup mais elle met pas mal de long
de points aussi
STEVE passons à la suite
alors on va enchaîner avec la deuxième
lorsque heureuse du 17 après après ma
longueur marine dursus
et oui donc qui a doublé aussi avec les
18 sur l'euro voilà donc
la mi 14,7 points par match 15,6
dévalles sur la sur les U17 c'est une
2005 au centre fédérale et c'est plutôt
une arrière à mettre 1 2 1m74 sur son
utilisation j'ai l'impression qu'elle
était plutôt utilisée en seconde
initiatrice
ce que j'aime bien chez elle c'est que
tout simplement elle est skillée et
technique une belle technique
en dribble shoot shoot elle a 12 sur 23
à 3 points sur la compétition
intelligente une belle variété de gamme
de passe de dribble écrit de la
séparation grâce à son dribble et après
le petit bémol que j'ai pour elle sur le
plus haut niveau c'est peut-être le
capacité justement à dribbler sous
pression
pour pouvoir être vraiment une première
initiatrice parce que son physique fait
que elle est peut-être obligée d'être
alignée avec une entre guillemets une
vraieuse de jeu donc ça c'est les
questions que je me pose sur elle mais
c'était très belle joueuse de basket et
ça a été ma mon coup de coeur un peu de
d'être tournois cet été chez ah ouais
bien sûr c'était la star quand je
regardais pas les matchs pour scooter je
regardais marine dure
romain
je suis pas objectif parce que c'est
pareil c'est un petit peu comme d'homme
c'est une joueuse que jamais énormément
je qu'est-ce que tu peux nous dire que
qui se voit pas forcément sur le film
alors que je peux dire qu'il se voit pas
forcément dessus bon déjà faut savoir
qu'en U18 statistiquement c'était les
performances sont un petit peu moindres
mais elle a été rappelée elle était
juste rentrée de compète les 18 partait
les terrassé pour pas d'une blessure
donc à la rejoint les U18 un petit peu
un petit peu petit bonheur la chance
avec seulement quelques jours de repos
dans les jambes et puis et puis repartir
donc ceci cela moi ce que j'ai beaucoup
aimé chez marine c'est et c'est rare
chez les filles
c'est ce côté plaisir d'offrir je vois
de recevoir dans le sens où plus ça
cogne plus LM donc il y a rien de soft
chez elle du tout et c'est ce qui fait
que pour moi malgré un
relativement de centimètre mais c'est
trompeur parce que malgré tout elle est
pas elle est lipide niant d'aller autour
du mètre 75 par contre elle est très
solide physiquement
et elle a une vraie capacité à défendre
tout ce que tu expliques Steve c'est
exactement le profil c'est-à-dire que ça
ne peut pas être une créatrice
principale
parce que ça ça fait trop d'informations
à gérer c'est quelqu'un qui un petit peu
bon c'est pas le même profil non plus
mais on pourra avoir eu pour avoir eu
Sarah Michel 2 ans à Nantes c'est un
petit peu comme ça c'est à dire que
c'est des gens qu'on composant d'avoir
la globalité et le cadre le cadre
général pour pouvoir s'exprimer dedans
et Marine a vraiment ce côté
ce côté déterminé et
cette capacité à jouer sans rien montrer
en termes d'émotion qui est super
intéressant parce que
elle fait le taf point parce qu'elle est
sur le terrain pour jouer pour gagner
quand on en difficulté qu'il faut aller
chercher des lancer francs qu'il faut
aller chercher des fautes elle met le
casque c'est elle va tout droit elle est
capable d'aller chercher le contact elle
a un sens du panier qui fait que même
sur un contact elle est capable ensuite
derrière de trouver le tir donc c'est
aussi pour ça que je vais regarder les
chiffres mais qu'elle était capable
d'aller sur la ligne des lancers et
typiquement notamment sur le sur le
sur la compète ouais c'est ça 27 lancer
sur la compète sur une rentabilité je
vais mettre sur les stats qui étaient
pas 21 sur 27 voilà 14 c'est quasiment
tenté par match
je sais que sur les sur le match
notamment contre le contre le Canada
quand elle part sur la ligne elle a fait
elle fait 8 10 relancer sur le contre le
Canada sur le banc on est totalement
serein quand elle va sur la ligne parce
que il y a des il y a des joueurs comme
ça ou des joueuses comme ça que j'ai
j'ai croisé que j'ai eu dans ma carrière
tu sais que c'est de l'argent la banque
c'est sur un match important elle doit
aller sur la ligne elle fait 8 10 et les
10 dans ses froid elle va aller chercher
donc
et puis voilà capacité à mettre les tirs
qui font mal en plus le Drive qui va
faire mal au casque le tir à 3 qui va
qui va qui va te couvrir un peu alors
son adresse est un petit peu un petit
peu
moyenne sur le match contre le Canada
mais moi ce que je donne c'est que c'est
le match où il faut les chercher le
médaille qu'elle prend 15 tir
c'est-à-dire un peu plus que ce qu'elle
prend habituellement sur la race de la
rencontre parce qu'il faut y aller et
puis malgré tout
la battage des deux côtés du terrain
donc
je pense je pense les cheveux croire que
les centimètres qui peut lui manquer
pour le très haut niveau elle est
compensera autrement
mais il y a une intelligence une
intelligence de jeu et puis une qualité
humaine chez marine qui sont
je lui souhaite comme à toutes les
autres je souhaite dire à y arriver
parce que c'est vraiment quelqu'un
d'intéresse et puis bon licencié à la
SIG si besoin était le préciser donc je
prêche pour ma paroisse
et j'avais noté moi intelligence
vous en avez déjà parlé et volume
c'est
intéressant à noter souvent chez les
jeunes joueurs et jeunes joueuses c'est
le volume et elle elle a un énorme
volume de jeu on voit on la voit
beaucoup quoi simplement clairement
exploiter aujourd'hui on perd on perd
contre l'Espagne en demi on joue le
bronze si on est en finale contre les
États-Unis je ne vois pas comment elle
peut ne pas dormir 5 dans la compétition
de la compétition
moi j'avais noté en piste puisque
effectivement je la vois pas trop poste
1 à terme
est-ce qu'elle est-ce qu'elle va
progresser sur les shoots après
mouvement parce que la chaîne shoot
c'est money enfin hyper à droite
maintenant voilà les chutes après
mouvement les après cours intense etc ça
a peut-être ce qui va ce qui va aussi
décider de de ce qu'on appelle
les discussions on prépare avec elle
tous les deux là elle a une capacité en
fait
elle a ce côté un cinq actif dans son
jeu qui fait que
elle va être capable de prendre le tir à
trois points sur la première intention
sur du sur des jeux de transition par
exemple
en fait il faut il faut ce que je vais
dire il y a absolument rien de péjoratif
ni de déplacer dans mon propos mais
Marine ne joue qu'en un garçon dans le
sens où il y a beaucoup de jeux à enfin
et il y a beaucoup de choses qu'elle a
pris exactement comme Marine Joannès
après énormément de choses du basket
masculin dans sa façon d'être et dans sa
forme dans sa façon d'être sur le
terrain et d'évoluer et Marine est
vraiment là-dessus et c'est super
intéressant parce que
à entraîné il y a pas de limite dans le
sens où
[Musique]
voilà c'est actif des deux côtés du
terrain ça comprend alors après pour
venir sur la question de que tu posais
tout à l'heure
spot-up elle peut du catch and shout
elle peut sans trop de problèmes sortie
d'écran c'est des choses qu'elle peut
maîtriser et après on sortit de riz le
pull-up de mémoire je ne sais plus je
crois je crois que le poulet mi distance
c'est quelque chose qu'elle doit pas
trop mal faire mais en général quand
elle pose la balle au sol et qu'elle
baisse la tête elle va au Cercle marine
dursus donc
la scolarus de cette équipe
U17 j'enchaîne avec la scorose de
l'équipe U16 en tout cas il me semble
que la meilleure
si c'était pas elle qui est dans le 5 de
la compétition
il me semble que c'est la meilleure
scolar alors je sais pas comment
prononce son nom puisque sur Youtube les
commentateurs sont en anglais les
commentaires sont en anglais c'est Inès
pitarc ou Pitarch Granel romain tu sais
quoi
ça sent un petit peu le nombre breton
donc
[Musique]
ce temps
quand même parce que
on a beaucoup de temps en Bretagne
mon beau-frère à ce nom-là il s'est dit
[ __ ]
on est là on est au dessus est-ce que
vous c'est incroyable ça c'est
incroyable quand même on est on n'a
jamais atteint ce niveau là
joueuse alors je sais pas c'est toujours
le cas
j'avais noté ça dans mes notes ou pas
Paul France mais licencié à La Tronche
Meylan
toutes les joueuses en fait toutes les
joueurs allaient jouer du du Centre
fédéral dans une double licence oui bien
sûr mais je veux dire la tronche mêlant
tu sais que c'est pas loin de chez moi
quoi
c'est les Alpes
donc 2006 mais 2006 un mètre 82 poste 2
3 on va dire
elle était
avec nail Angloma sur les postes alignés
sur les postes de droit et je pense sans
trop me tromper que
sans enfin ce sont les peut-être
défensivement c'était le meilleur duo à
l'aile défensivement et même trio on
peut rajouter
c'était très
global sur l'impact physique parce que
réalisacher le peu que j'en ai vu elle a
pas tout à fait l'impact par contre
engloma et [ __ ] ce Gravel bon courage
au poste 3 adverses parce que il y a
vraiment vraiment l'une comme l'autre
tiens la Batache physique parenthèse
belle englomase c'est la c'est la nièce
de Monsieur
donc le sport le sport reste dans la
famille
en plus d'être
d'avoir différentes qualités des
différentes qualités artistiques autres
les deux il y a du vrai volume moi plus
tard je ramène j'ai pas vu jouer
suffisamment pour pour pareil pour le
peu que j'en ai vu un vrai un vrai
volume une vraie rentabilité aussi
j'ai noté ça gros moteur
elle adore driver main gauche alors
qu'elle retire mais voilà en défense
j'ai vu des choses que je n'ai jamais vu
sur un U16 avec une joueuse d'un mètre
82 des clausades où elle arrive elle est
pas en plein sprint mais elle a pas
quatre courses 85 % et bien
la joueuse adverse drive je parle je
parle de la finale contre l'Espagne
joueuse adverse drive elle est capable
de tourner les hanches de garder
l'attitude défensive d'aller contester
et de contrer proprement sans faire
faute c'est très très fort franchement
c'est très très fort défensivement bon
jeu de jambes gros premier pas pour sa
taille
elle tente que 9 3 points sur la compète
donc c'est assez dur à dire au niveau du
tir comment ça va se développer mais
voilà il y a déjà le moteur
c'est pour moi c'est très comme on dit
brut encore voilà
d'habitude parce qu'on fait des des
anglicismes mais voilà elle est encore
très brute sur sur sur tout ce qui est
capacités techniques voilà elle dribble
surtout en ligne droite sur tout main
gauche elle a pas un énorme touché près
du cercle en tout cas quand le niveau de
compétition c'est élevé elle a eu un
petit peu de mal voilà à
finir près du cercle mais mais c'est
comme comme
Ursus sur les sur les U17 on voyait
quasiment enfin vous voyez pas qu'elle
parce qu'il y avait un vrai collectif
non success mais
on la voyait beaucoup sur le terrain
elle a beaucoup apporté à cette équipe
et on sent qu'il y a un état d'esprit de
voilà de d'aller castagner l'adversaire
et de et de lui faire mal donc Steve je
sais pas si tu as quelque chose à
ajouter sur Peter grahamel mais
pour aller dans le sens de ce que vous
disiez
sur les rebonds elle est impressionnante
je vous extérieur je sais plus à la
combien mais j'avais vu c'était 5 9
ouais voilà 5 9 pour une deux trois
c'est c'est une projection à 18 minutes
elle a 2,3 broches en 18 minutes
donc c'est assez impressionnant et
effectivement gros volume super appui je
trouve
très bien on enchaîne bah du coup on va
enchaîner avec sa compère Neil angle
mort
donc 2 3
[Musique]
qui était en fait qui était d'abord avec
nous ce que la priorité avait été donnée
sur la préparation pour Nell et pour et
pour théâtre de faire la compète de
faire l'ACM la Coupe du Monde et ensuite
rebasculer rebasculer avec leur
génération sur sur le U16 c'est une
manière aussi de faire prendre à ces
deux joueuses la spécifiquement
du volume et de l'expérience
internationale parce que l'occasion se
présentait et c'est sûrement aussi une
des raisons en plus du boulot qu'elles
ont fait avec le stade puis 16 après qui
a permis annel comme Athéa d'arriver en
fait en U16 avec déjà une expérience une
expérience de compète qui est ce qui est
tout sauf négligeable à cet âge-là
absolument donc Steve elle est née en
juin 2006 un mètre 82 Centre Fédéral par
le mois de son jeu
déjà son physique on a parlé un petit
peu mais les très larges d'épaules très
costauds
donc elle a une grosse capacité à driver
très très forte dans le drive elle finit
main droite main gauche j'ai vu des
belles finitions main gauche
elle a été à droite sur le tournoi mais
sur un échantillon qui va me
relativement faible elle fait cette
surprise à trois points la témoin allait
sur le 17 ou le fait de 10 mais elle a
été capable de mettre des tirs
importants même si je trouve que la
gestuelle s'améliorer notamment la
trajectoire de tir mais c'est une
joueuse qui est très très dans
l'agression du cercle tout le temps très
forte là dessus et en défense que vous
l'avez dit sur la défense porteur
beaucoup d'impact beaucoup d'impact donc
je vous dis pas intéressantes aussi il
faut se lever de bonheur pour pour faire
le tour de nail Angloma parce que large
bien et elle est large et vraiment c'est
impressionnant pour son âge j'étais
hyper impressionné je savais pas qu'elle
était surclassé quand romain il m'a dit
qu'elle allait faire le UC j'ai dit ah
d'accord
moi j'ai adoré sur le U17 le match
médaille de bronze elle joue que 11
minutes mais par contre sur les 11
minutes elle est impeccable elle fait
quasiment pas une erreur elle a un nom
de mon très très précieuse elle était
elle est passée un peu à travers contre
l'Espagne
ou même entrave complet contre l'Espagne
et elle était très utile contre son
deuxième passage de mémoire contre le
Canada et et très précieux et elle nous
fait du bien c'est après c'est
on est toujours super exigeant avec ces
jeunes joueuses
mais faut pas oublier en étant N-1 elle
est encore dans l'apprentissage plus que
d'autres et une année d'âge à ces
moments-là en terme de carrière
développement c'est énorme bien sûr donc
on est parfois très exigeant avec avec
avec ses filles là
mais il y a aussi le fait qu'elle soit
qu'elle soit le moins malgré tout elle a
été voilà c'est quelqu'un qui sur et en
dehors du terrain à un vrai rôle à jouer
dans cette équipe
et je pense que à l'avenir c'est
quelqu'un qui peut avoir un potentiel
pro oui effectivement
moi j'ai mis top 3 prospects cette
équipe U17 bah du coup on va parler de
ta Cléante qui elle aussi était
surclassée et qui a terminé dans le 5 de
la compétition
U16 et qui avait un beau temps de jeu en
U17 aussi
et dans le 5 même parfois pas tout le
temps
mais
un mètre 76 Centre Fédéral né en mai
alors très fine c'est évidemment le le
point faible et d'ailleurs en finale U16
contre l'Espagne elle galère un petit
peu face à
caryon c'est Carion je crois là
il y a une meuleuse de jeu incroyable
elle est extraordinaire j'ai eu la
menace de jeu espagnol et ça me fait mal
de le dire mais j'ose incroyable elle
est extraordinaire de pour son âge elle
fait des choses vraiment très très
avancées ça fait penser à des meneurs
potentiels qu'on a vu aussi chez
masculin dont on nous a déjà parlé mais
c'est vraiment très très très
impressionnant donc elle a eu un peu de
mal face à carriole qui est une très
bonne joueuse très bien mais du coup
c'était plus la
meneuse remplaçante de cette équipe de
France U16 c'était la Colas Cola qui a
qui se coltinait qui était plus efficace
sur sur carriole en finale
maintenant voilà tu es accueillante et
propre
sur le U17 23 pass 11 balles perdues
donc ça veut dire que c'est généralement
dire c'est bon signe quoi
défensivement même si elle est fine elle
anticipe souvent assez bien je sais pas
à quel on n'a pas les mesures
d'envergure à cet âge-là mais elle a
l'air d'avoir des plutôt l'ombrage
j'aime les lignes de passe et souvent
bien placée
maintenant
la grosse marge de progression pour moi
c'est de jouer sous pression quand il y
a une défense forte qui met de la
pression en face elle a eu beaucoup de
mal sur le U17 mais voilà je sur le je
parle vite fait du tir catch and shoot
c'est carré ça part bien maintenant sur
sur le reste il y a encore du travail à
faire dans le voilà dans le placement
des appuis la coordination l'alignement
et c'est normal et jeune mais le catch
and shout en tout cas il y a déjà du
toucher elle a déjà de l'adresse donc
c'est une bonne c'est une même si elle
fait 6 sur 20 sur la compétition elle
est plus à droite que ça je pense donc
vraiment
une belle joueuse je sais pas ce que tu
as ajouté en bas
pareil il y a du basket du basket dans
la famille parce que le les parents tous
les deux étaient joueurs professionnels
théâtre c'est quelqu'un qui
encore vraiment au développement
qui a énormément avancé la saison
dernière parce que il y a eu un gros
boulot de faire avec elle au Centre
Fédéral soit avec avec Arnaud avec
Vincent notamment les deux les deux
coachs qui étaient responsables la
saison dernière du groupe du groupe qui
évolue en NF1 c'est quelqu'un qui
[Musique]
qui aujourd'hui
montre les capacités à scorer mais qui
doit également gagner en régularité
notamment sur le tir parce que
c'est pour l'instant une joueuse un
petit peu de série dans le sens où si
prometon dedans ça peut ça peut très
bien se passer mais si le premier pas
dedans ça peut ça peut vite gamberger
donc c'est un petit peu ça limite à
l'heure actuelle mais c'est quand même
qui joue avec vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie et qui est capable quand elle
quand elle en fait la démarche et quand
elle le veut de verrouiller un
adversaire défensivement parlant de
manière de manière très très
impressionnante je dirais que le petit
truc qui qui lui faut à l'heure actuelle
c'est de
[Musique]
la puissance et puis l'appréhension du
l'appréhension du rôle du rôle et du
poste de jeu qu'elle va avoir ou à
certains moments il faut qu'elle gère un
petit peu mieux ses rites cet enfant
c'est en faible et qu'elle apprenne
aussi mais ça c'est l'âge c'est normal
c'est pour ça que c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on peut lire reprocher
aujourd'hui de de penser aussi à gérer
les choses pour les autres et c'est
en comment dire en ayant la bonne la
bonne démarche par rapport à tout ça ça
peut être une jouer jusqu'à qui a une
vraie potentialité aujourd'hui une
certitude
nous on U17 elle a elle a elle a des
moments où j'étais petit moment de moins
bien mais encore une fois quand on prend
une fille comme ça pour la développer on
accepte qui est qui est un peu moins
bien sur certaines séquences au
demeurant bon au 19 fois qu'on t'a
Slovénie qui était une équipe
intéressante en Allemagne en quart de
finale la compréhende
en 2000 c'est convenable elle à 5 pages
ici cette score pas trop et qu'on te le
Canada où elle s'étale un petit peu mais
malgré tout vous pouvez lui reprocher
sur l'investissement on peut pas
approcher ce qu'elle a ce qu'elle a
essayé de faire aussi des deux côtés du
terrain parce que c'est qu'un autre qui
laisse une telle élargir défense que
après faut apprendre à trouver des des
ficelles pour rester un petit peu lucide
tout long et ça bon bah quand on joue
quand on joue tout le temps à 100% c'est
pas simple bien sûr c'est un métier une
heure de jeu
Steve on va essayer d'aller un peu plus
vite sur les profils qui restent même si
moi il reste chouchou mais bon
inouïe 13 de U16 tu vois après
[Musique]
je vais prendre la
tireuse la shooteuse de l'équipe
Clémence Colin
quel bras voilà gaucher bras gauche donc
un deux un mètre 72 petit gabarit mince
Bourges
le club en pas l'attitude
les Tangos voilà de Bourges pour être
précis et donc 14 32 14 sur 32 à 3
points sur sur le tournoi et en
particulier en finale où elle sort elle
sort match du tournoi
notamment pour sauter la zone elle
attire qui est assez joli à regarder
parce que le fouetter est vraiment
superbe un bal tourne très très bien la
balle par très haut elle tire plutôt en
alternatif il me semble
je sais plus ça fait gauche-droite tout
droit de gauche mais
elle tire souvent sur un avalternatif
elle tient assez vite même si le ballon
part d'un peu bas mais c'est ça dégaine
vite ça dégaine souvent sans hésitation
donc
voilà Clémence Colin ouais
poste 2
comment dire à vocation à vocation
shoutteuse parce que bon dans la lignée
des chloément il y a quelques années qui
étaient des Alpes également ou plus
récemment que j'avais moins U17 déjà de
Ferré
c'est les profils qu'on retrouve souvent
dans ce club là c'est assez marrant et
ils arrivent vraiment à bien les
développer
vraiment impressionnant si vous avez
l'occasion de voir sa finale contre
l'Espagne elle roule dessus la France ne
gagne pas le match Saint-Clément scolin
c'est certain
justement on reste à Bourges jade ferai
qui est pour enfin qui est la joueuse
que j'ai préféré presque
de cette équipe U17 elle avait le
malheur peut-être de jouer à peu près
sur le même poste que Marine dursus donc
forcément ça ça réduit son temps de jeu
donc
post 1 2 1m76
avril 2005 donc là je normal pour cette
compétition
pour moi elle peut déjà elle cédribbler
elle s'est passé elle s'est shootée elle
était pas du tout elle était pas du tout
elle était pas vraiment réussite sur sur
la compétition U17 elle fait 8 sur 32
mais le volume 32/3 ça veut dire qu'il y
a de la confiance on parle souvent du
volume comme du d'un truc qui peut
prédire aussi l'adresse au final et moi
je trouve que que c'est le cas pour elle
le shoot est stable il y a sur le drive
il y a aussi déjà une technique que j'ai
bien aimé il y a de l'ambidé d'extri ça
la rend dangereuse voilà pour les
défenses dans le drive
défensivement elle m'a semblé assez vive
alors peut-être pas assez encore au
contact mais mais pas non plus à le fuir
j'ai noté en tout cas que peut-être la
difficulté de se serait décidé si elle
serait une poste de ou une poste 1
puisque puisque pour moi la le Hamburg
peut-être pour jouer un terme je sais
pas si elle a la vision c'était
difficile à dire sur la compète
mais mais si le tire rentre avec
régularité
et qu'elle peut tirer en sortie de
dribble quand ça passe sous l'écran et
avec le handle qu'elle a avec le le les
deux mains le capacité à la passe la
capacité de voir le jeu moi je pense que
que ça pourrait faire une chose pro
romain je sais pas des choses
moi c'est quelqu'un avec qui bon c'est
quelques jouets sur cette génération à
qui je me suis très bien entendu dans le
travail et dans les échanges et Jade
j'adore fait partie parce que c'est
une personnalité assez atypique
quelqu'un de très direct et qui a du mal
à
ne pas dire les choses donc c'est moi
j'aime bien travailler que les gens
comme ça
je pense que
post-1 ça me paraît compliqué elle peut
dépanner aujourd'hui sur ces catégories
là mais postes ça me paraît compliqué
parce qu'elle a moins d'information
gérée par contre c'est quelqu'un s'il
arrive à achever ça
ça transition dans un rôle de shoot
ospure je pense que ça peut être très
intéressant parce que elle aime tirer
elle a déjà des routines elle est très
mature dans son approche elle aime tirer
elle a une capacité à
vraiment pouvoir prendre des tirs y
compris de loin après avec nous
effectivement la feuille bol parce que
sur les sur les tirs qu'elle prend
globalement il y a pas grand chose de il
y a pas grand chose de forcer il y a pas
grand chose à acheter c'est juste que
bah malgré tout malheureusement elle
n'est pas dedans
donc l'Espagne et franchement il y en a
qui méritent de rentrer enfin on dit ça
mérite jamais de rentrer mais voilà mais
globalement globalement sur l'ensemble
de la compète je l'ai vu forcer petit
mais le 25 contre l'Allemagne il est pas
il est cher payé le 1 8 contre Espagne
il est cher payé
après c'est quelqu'un qui a envie de
bien faire sur trop de pression aussi et
c'est des petites choses à réguler donc
encore une fois c'est c'est des jeunes
joueuses en développement mais moi c'est
typiquement le genre de personne
je n'ai aucun mal à passer du temps à
travailler avec puisque c'est des gens
qui vont toujours
te rendre l'investissement que tu as eu
en termes de temps quand tu entraînes
par de l'engagement sur le terrain et
par une loyauté un respect des valeurs
dans lesquelles elles évoluent qui
rendent le boulot tellement facile
après est-ce que c'est un potentiel pro
à terme je lui souhaite l'igoulick 2 je
sais pas et c'est l'avenir le dira mais
en tout cas il y a une vraie qualité de
tir qui m'a fait que la qualité humaine
donc c'est moi pour moi il y a il y a
tout pour avoir envie de s'en occuper et
la développer j'adéré donc la joueuse de
Bourges
Steve il nous reste une joueuse du
l'équipe
U16 une joueuse interieur qui au Centre
Fédéral aussi oui ça ne fédéral
surclassé 2007 alors que les haché c'est
du juillet 2007
donc un rôle assez limité un mètre 89
pardon en relacilé assez limité dans
l'équipe parce que c'était vraiment une
équipe qui était tournée quand même sur
ces choses extérieures ces jouets
vraiment avec 4 externe une chose
intérieure qui était là pour poser des
écrans et puis s'écartait libérer le
couloir de un contrat mais elle a elle a
une vraie combinaison taille mobilité
qui est intéressante
parce qu'elle bouge bien pour un mètre
89 et jeune aussi après il y a du
travail notamment sur la sur l'adresse
sur les mains je trouve que à la elle
peut faire beaucoup mieux sur les tirs
proches du cercle mais c'est une chose
qui peut être intéressante à terme voilà
absolument Sarah Sarah Cissé qu'on a
décidé de mettre en lumière
niveau des profils je vais quand même
citer toutes les autres qui ont été
championne d'Europe
U16 et que et dont on n'a pas encore
parlé nous avons Myriam Traoré nous
avons
Aino à Rio nous avons Sarah
Ivana ça Ivana ouais keboumbia mot
Mélissa Guillet et Stella Cola donc j'ai
déjà mentionné le nom et à nous brun
et pour finir on va faire un petit shoot
out
puisque c'est la joueuse romain à qui tu
avais promis la médaille et et qui s'est
qui a fait son meilleur match peut-être
de la compétition pour pour le match de
la troisième place elle a peut-être été
un peu petite pour jouer en pro mais on
ne pouvait qu'aimer son jeu quand on la
regardait jouer au U17 c'est Inès Salaï
la Meuse de poche 1m69 sans trop fédéral
également énergie incroyable voilà elle
fait un très très gros match sur
notamment dans le clutch face face au
Canada et puis elle a bon elle vole
beaucoup de ballons et elle a un truc
qui est rare alors elle a un bon haundle
une bonne technique de passe etc c'est
tout classique pour le poste de meneur
elle se crée de l'espace beaucoup
toute seule c'est à dire des step back
des et des changements de rythme des
arrêts soudains qui vont créer
énormément d'espace et ce qui lui permet
de compenser sa taille parfois donc donc
elle est intéressante peut-être
développer un vrai tir méditant pour
pour être une piste pour pour voir pour
aller aller vers le niveau professionnel
on dit on dit des joueuses comme Inès
moi j'ai son maillot accroché juste
derrière moi donc c'est une très belle
rencontre également
on dit des joueuses comme Inès qu'elles
ont les cabinets de leurs défauts et
c'est quelqu'un qui qui peut vous rendre
complètement dingue au quotidien ce
qu'elle parle tout le temps d'être tout
le temps d'énergie et compagnie mais le
côté Zébulon vous avez sur le terrain et
là en dehors et inversement c'est à dire
que elle est sur le terrain comme elle
est au quotidien
c'est à dire à la fois génial et
épuisante
à définir puisqu'elle fait pas et je ne
joue et j'ai passé un temps incroyable
avec elle parce que une vraie envie de
bosser et puisque ce que ce que j'ai
aimé avec la plupart des défis de ce
groupe U17 c'est une vraie détermination
puis on aura envie de cogner les
adversaires au sens figuré j'entends
bien sûr et puis un côté clutch contre
le Canada c'est c'est ni plus ni moins
se sentir à trois qui c'est le travail
d'adjan le travail défensif à jackan et
lancer front de marine et puis le le tir
à 3 de d'Inès à quelques secondes de la
fin celui qu'elle met et celui qu'elle
prend en secret un petit peu à l'arrache
et la présence d'esprit du
volontairement de faire monter la balle
très très très haut sur le tir pour
bouffer le chrono pour que les secondes
tombent pendant que la balle est en
l'air mais ouais quelqu'un qui qui
comprend le jeu je vais juste dire
plusieurs fois pendant la campagne
d'arrêter de jouer comme comme si elle
était sur la plage à Copacabana avec ses
camarades à jouer au foot je lui je lui
dis plusieurs fois mais littéralement
arrête de jouer à la brésilienne et il
met un peu de cadre et c'est ce que je
lui dis sur sur une des sorties avant
qu'elle rentre en fait sur le dernier
run la courte Cala qu'elle soit un peu
plus contrôles mais c'est des gens qu'on
des profits de joueuses qui ont de
l'instinct et de la créativité qui font
que les brider ça ne sert à rien il faut
accepter la prise de risque parce que le
jour la prise de risque elle est bonne
bah ça paye ça paye et à défendre c'est
un vrai problème parce que comme tu l'as
dit chez les filles c'est rares des gens
consacapacité à se créer de l'espace
pour tirer sur les équipes ont une
malheur de switcher avec elle quand elle
s'est retrouvé face à des grands elle
s'amuse elle s'amuse elle s'amuse à les
promener et à se créer après le meltyro
elle le met pas mais c'est typiquement
des joueuses
si vous voulez être embêté quand vous
les défendez il faut les faire s'amuser
c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du moment elle
commence à rigoler et à se faire plaisir
sur le terrain c'est infernal parce que
elle est dans le rythme qu'elle veut
c'est elle fait partie de ces profils de
gens j'ai eu sa Rondeau comme ça il y a
quelques années à Nantes qui ont besoin
de s'amuser marine Joannès c'est un
petit peu pareil comme ça elle a besoin
de jouer aussi c'est des gens quand ils
sont des gens d'instin comme ça quand
ils commencent à sentir qu'ils peuvent
jouer avec avec leur partenaire avec
l'adversaire c'est terrible et ce
qu'elle va grandir romain où est-ce
qu'elle a fini vous savez pas je ne sais
pas je ne connais pas la j'ai passé
que l'été avec donc j'ai pas la cour de
croissance du carnet de santé je ne suis
pas sûr que les sœurs soient très
grandes parce que c'est sûr on jouait au
moins une sœur qui joue à bon niveau je
sais pas si elle va passer par le Centre
Fédéral pendant un an déjà aussi
mais en tout cas
en tout cas des qualités à faire voir
leur malgré tout notamment dans la dans
la capacité à passer à créer après il y
a un jeu à risque mais bon bien sûr
un petit peu trop mais comme elle quand
elle est elle en tant que personne donc
donc c'est je suis soit d'y arriver
pareil comme à toutes les autres parce
que
c'est toujours pareil enfin j'ai l'air
un peu un peu moins comment dire un peu
moins
[Musique]
un peu moins tranchant que je peux
l'être avec certains certains certains
prospects dont on parlait dessus mais là
j'ai vraiment passé un mois et demi avec
et le fait d'être avec le groupe et de
d'aller chercher quelque chose en termes
d'accomplissement à la fin d'aller
chercher de médaille
ça fausse peut-être mon jugement j'en
sais rien mais j'ai une perception
différente des joueuses parce que je
sais sur quoi
sur quoi m'appuyer ou pas avec elle et
concernant et je sais sur qui on peut
compter ou pas en termes de profil et
c'est pour ça que tout toute seule dont
on a parlé je leur souhaite purement et
simplement d'avoir une belle carrière et
on citera aussi les autres médaillés la
capitaine je crois qu'il y a Captain
Isaline Saunier
fleur morale qui a moins joué Isaline a
beaucoup a quand même pas mal joué Maëva
Marc à jackan on l'a cité à plusieurs
reprises et Léa Joko et je crois que je
n'aurais oublié personne bah il va
marquer par la petite anecdote on va
finir sur quelque chose de drôle
les joueuses comme le staff on passe un
petit peu de temps à regarder le
flambeau avant le début de la campagne
et c'est devenu en fait en milieu en
milieu de compétition à running gag de
hurler Marc en passant derrière elle
pour la faire sursauter et c'est
tellement devenir que ça nous a tenu sur
les trois quarts d'années jour jusqu'à
jusque dans l'Uber qui nous a amené de
de l'aéroport à la gare Montparnasse ou
aller le malheur de s'endormir donc
voilà je vous laisse imaginer le réveil
c'est aussi le genre de running gag qui
fait qui s'ouvre une équipe
entre parenthèses elle va Marc comprend
comme Catherine intérieur
qui a une progression qui est à Bourges
également et on sent que Virgile qui
s'en occupait à Bourges la saison
dernière Virgile est Virgile et Benoît
qui qui est toujours là sur son de
formation cette année on fait un vrai
travail avec elle et nous c'était une
surprise très intéressante parce que une
joueuse qui avait été vue plusieurs fois
ces dernières années sur laquelle on
avait des hésitations mais une capacité
à passer la balle pour une 5
rares vraiment parce que jamais de
mauvais choix très très peu de balles
perdues dans le dans le jeu et dans les
lectures sur la compétition
ce qui est déjà quelque chose et puis
elle a un profil un peu dégâts Antel un
peu caoutchouteux mais moi j'ai fini par
la surnommer le de
Saint-Jean-Pied-de-Port à la fin dans le
sens où déjà parce qu'elle est du coin
là-bas d'une part et d'autre part
64 c'était pour le pour le côté le côté
en bas les PA et surtout une vraie
dureté c'est à dire que c'est une
joueuse c'est une joueuse qui est
intelligente dans le jeu sans ballon qui
s'est toujours se placer correctement ce
qui s'est passé la balle et puis s'il
faut aller mettre une tartine elle va
mettre une partie et malgré tout capable
de gens s'enrichissent donc elle pour le
je mets une petite mention d'orable
parce que
1m95 parce que des segments et puis
parce que je vous intérieur donc
peut-être que dans 4-5 ans on la verra
arriver sur du haut niveau aussi je lui
souhaite également parce que il y a du
travail et puis parce que nous a fait
alors elle a pas forcément toujours
beaucoup joué mais les trois quatre
minutes qu'on lui a donné par ci par là
sur certains matchs y compris je suis
allé sur les matchs coupe près ils nous
ont fait du bien parce que la présence
parce que si parce que ça voilà et si je
peux me permettre aux mains le un mur à
Saint-Jean-Pied-de-Port ça s'appelle un
fronton du coup
n'étant pas pelotarie de base et
j'ai pas voulu pousser le cliché jusque
là mais c'est vrai que la joueuse il
joueuse allemande dont j'ai oublié le
nom qui était à Forbach à 30 points
avant de nous jouer elle a fait
connaissance avec elle
par exemple sur quelqu'un qui quelqu'un
qui blague à part et qui attend une
vraie dureté sur le terrain et ça pour
les joueuses de grande taille c'est pas
toujours quelque chose de facile pour
plein de raisons c'est toujours
intéressant parce que c'est les
comportements qui sont rassurants pour
nous pour notre traîne parce que quelque
part on sait que bah si à chantier ça
peut répondre et c'est toujours c'est
toujours important voilà donc nous avons
conclu ce
ce podcast
présumé des équipes de France féminine
U17 et U16 la campagne 2022 avec une
médaille de bronze pour les U17 au monde
et une médaille d'or pour les U16 au
championnat d'Europe nous avons conclu
sur Saint-Jean-Pied-de-Port et ça me
fait grand plaisir parce que c'est une
très belle région le Pays Basque merci
beaucoup Steve de rien c'est un plaisir
on te retrouve bientôt probablement pour
pour début des profils la NCA se
rapproche début de la saison ici se
rapproche et puis romain et bien bon
courage pour pour cette cette Coupe
d'Europe que vous allez jouer la
prochainement on enregistre le lundi 3
octobre vous avez un match bientôt et
puis pour mercredi
et ensuite à tourner se poursuivra
Cholet samedi voilà
normalement contre un club hongrois si
on a bien compris ça devrait aller
puisque la Hongrie a l'air de portée
bonheur
merci à tous de nous avoir écoutés
donnez-nous donnez-nous des notes sur
les applis on adore les notes
donc donner des notes et abonnez-vous
comme ça vous aurez la notif quand le
podcast sortira ciao tout le monde